good eating everybody tonight the
Republicans and Democrats in Congress
have come together around an agreement
that will reopen our government and
remove the threat of default from our
economy the Senate has now voted to
approve this agreement and Democrats and
Republicans in the House still have an
important vote to take but I want to
thank the leaders of both parties for
getting us to this point once this
agreement arrives on my desk I will sign
it immediately we'll begin reopening our
government immediately and we can begin
to lift this cloud of uncertainty and
unease from our businesses and from the
American people I'll have more to say
about this tomorrow and I've got some
thoughts about how we can move forward
in the remainder of the year stay
focused on the job at hand because
there's a lot of work ahead of us
including our need to earn back the
trust of the American people that's been
lost over the last few weeks and we can
begin to do that by addressing the real
issues that they care about I've said it
before I'll say it again I'm willing to
work with anybody I am eager to work
with anybody Democrat or Republican
House or Senate members on any idea that
will grow our economy create new jobs
strengthen the middle class and get our
fiscal house in order for the long term
I've never believed that Democrats have
a monopoly on good ideas and despite the
differences over the issue of shutting
down our government I'm convinced that
Democrats and Republicans can work
together to make progress for America in
fact there are things that we know will
help strengthen our economy that we
could get done before this year is out
we still need to pass a lot of fix our
broken immigration system we still need
to pass a farm bill and with the
shutdown behind us and budget committees
forming we now have an opportunity to
focus on a sensible budget that is
responsible that is fair and that helps
hard-working people all across this
country and we could get all these
things done
this year if everybody comes together in
a spirit of how are we going to move
this country forward and put the last
three weeks behind us that's what I
believe the American people are looking
for not a focus on politics now to focus
on elections but a focus on the concrete
steps that can improve their lives
that's going to be my focus i'm looking
forward to congress doing the same but
once again I want to thank the
leadership for coming together and
getting this done hopefully next time it
won't be in the eleventh hour one of the
things that I said throughout this
process is we've got to get out of the
habit of governing by crisis and my hope
and expectation is everybody has learned
that there's no reason why we can't work
on the issues at hand why we can't
disagree between the parties while still
being agreeable and make sure that we're
not inflicting harm on the American
people when we do have disagreements so
hopefully that's a lesson that will be
internalized and not just by by me but
also by Democrats and Republicans not
only the leaders but also the
rank-and-file thanks very much really
you